hi i'm jessica alba and this is me
getting honest with glamour uk
i grew up in um a mexican-american
family and they really
feel like
girls hair should be long
when i started acting i actually got a
haircut from chris mcmillan
who did the rachel cut from friends and
i i think it was actually my first
official haircut that my mom didn't give
me
um and my hair was down to my butt
and when i came home with the rachel cut
it was like these like
really um
extreme layers
my dad tried to ground me
it was so crazy i just kind of feel like
hair you should just have fun with it
and
it grows
so
[Applause]
[Music]
yes i
believe that i have identified as a
feminist
since i could remember
identifying as anything i do believe
that women should be equal to men and so
does my dad
there you go my dad's a feminist too
[Applause]
true story
he did
[Applause]
that is the truth
i've been in so many makeup chairs since
i was 12 years old and i cannot even
tell you the countless amount of eczema
rashes
and
random acne and things that would just
happen to my face because of all of the
products i mean i would have sneezing
fits my eyes would swell i would get
giant welts underneath my eyes
it makes the close-ups
actually impossible
so yeah i created honest beauty because
i was sick of having those types of
reactions true story
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah isn't that weird
i'm i'm still surprised
it was called the honest life or it is
called the honest life
yeah there you go
[Applause]
i think the uk and europe has a great
standard
and at the time there were only like 11
chemicals banned in the united states
and over a thousand banned in europe and
uk and i just wanted us
in our country to at least meet that
standard so
[Applause]
i know the sun is not good for the skin
i know
but
i just love it i just love being out in
nature i love taking hikes i love
all the beaches like i really haven't
met too many beaches that i don't like
as long as there's
a warm sun
involved
[Applause]
i definitely grew up in a household
where we recycled upcycled
uh everything
there was really very little waste
and my grandmother would macgyver
everything
everything had like five purposes let me
tell you